sam coats
mr teigen hat
first of all you just talked about the
need for an election how soon do you
think there should be an election are
you talking about cutting short this
parliament down the road in another
leadership uh
uh contest launch it's incredible to
believe that there's more than one at
the moment dominic rabb has just said
that this is no time to learn on the job
he's right isn't he and finally you
opened your speech by talking about
britishness we've also talked about
being a dual national you have a french
mother what have you learned uh from
that by being a jew national sure well i
think the first thing i've learned
about being a dual national is that i
should have chosen my mother better
when i decided
to go into politics
there's only so many things i can change
sam that's not one of them
the reality is
that the
job of prime minister is unlike every
other job in government
it's not a management job
it's not a departmental job
it's a job that demands vision and
leadership
it demands
a willingness to serve
and throw everything
in the duty of serving the british
people
this is no time to learn
what this is is a time to look at a
record of service
a record of delivery
under the most difficult and trying
conditions around the world
and see that this isn't learning on the
job
this is putting all that experience to
work
on the job
and the best job and the hardest job in
the united kingdom
there is
two years to go before a general
election at least now
there is no
mandate for an early one
what there is is a mandate for a new
leader
what we need is we need a new leader
to deliver and when i am prime minister
i will be rolling out a new deal for
britain
that will demonstrate
how we're delivering
before i go to the country and ask them
to trust us again because we need to
rebuild trust
we're only going to do it if we get a
clean start
and the right team around that table
thank you